president biden says belarus committed
shameful assaults on dissent
and freedom of the press by diverting a
commercial jet
and removing one of its high-profile
critics from the plane
elizabeth palmer is tracking the fate of
that opposition journalist liz good
morning
good morning well after he was pulled
off the plane
on sunday night ramon protested
disappeared into custody
and then a full 24 hours later he showed
up again
in this video
it was released on the government social
media channel apparently filmed by the
police
it's no secret that pratasiyevich was a
key figure in the movement opposed to
belarus's authoritarian president
alexander lukashenko but family and
friends say this confession was forced
and note a visible bruise on his
forehead this is an attack
on democracy european leaders have been
quick to react to the fake bomb scare on
sunday that diverted a ryan airplane to
minsk
just so belarusian security forces could
arrest pertacievich
and belarus used its control over its
airspace in order to perpetrate
a state hijacking european governments
have not only ordered their planes to
avoid
air space but they'll also close their
airports to bella russian planes
and sanction figures involved in the
hijacking
after police attacked and arrested
anti-lukashenko protesters
thousands of young belarusians including
praticiewicz
fled abroad for safety franek villavorka
is one of them
how much more afraid are you
and your colleagues today than you were
last week
i'm afraid of my life now
no one can feel safe even if you are
traveling abroad we
know that we might be followed
but they don't know what president
lukashenko
brazen enough to force down a civilian
jet to see as a political dissident
might do for an enclosure
president biden joined european leaders
calling for
protestievic's release but the chances
of that are practically
zero realistically like hundreds of
other political prisoners in belarus
she's probably facing
many years in jail gail very frightening
situation there thank you very much
elizabeth reporting from london